Before you tackle the next mini project,
I want you to hear from Scott Murray again.
Scott has some excellent advice for breaking into the field.
If you could go back and sort of give yourself advice for
when you first started in the field.
When you first started making individualizations, what advice would that be?
>> My advice would be.
To just find topics I'm really excited about and go pursue them,
which I sort of did.
But secondly, to get that stuff published and
out on the web and start sharing it, like, sooner.
I know with sort of my personal experience there's this feeling.
Like, I can't put something out into the world until it's, like, polished and
finished and perfect and really exciting or amazing.
I know students get that a lot, too.
It can be really intimidating.
Especially if you're studying works by people who are doing you know,
at least on paper having all kinds of a success.
And like, doing all these amazing projects.
It can be really intimidating to be like, oh, here's this little chart I made.
Or here's this you know, thing that's so, feels so
insignificant or it might have problems.
But I think really that's how you get established in this,
probably in a lot of fields.
But especially in this field where it's all about sharing and
this visual communication.
And then, having people respond to that graphic.
because the graphics are not just kind of endpoints, or
the visualizations aren't just endpoints.
But they're really sort of you know starting points for
the rest of the conversation.
So one thing this is especially true I guess for
design students as in you have to do it now.
You know, you have to have a web based portfolio.
You have to have something on the web where you can publish things and
get it out there.
And like engage people and get a response.
So I would say you know, start making stuff as quick as you can and
start putting it out there as quick as you can.
And certainly engaging with other practitioners and
you know, critiquing in a helpful way.
So trying to provide helpful advice and
not just It's kind of too easy to cut down the things that aren't very good.
like, there's been some discussion, kind of in the community,
about this recently.
On what's the value of critique?
And what kind of critique is helpful?
Somebody uses you know, quote, unquote, bad colors it's very easy to be like,
oh, well those are you know, horrible colors.
It makes it too hard to read, or something.
Instead of saying, those are horrible colors.
Say you know, maybe this is somebody new who's coming in.
And they're trying to learn how to do a good job.
Encourage them with hey, why don't, can I suggest these better colors?
Or, can I suggest this other visual representation.
So I think part of it is, you know, getting your stuff out there.
But it's also being friendly and supportive and you know, hopefully kind and
empathizing with the people who are new, who are just coming in.
>> Okay.
Great.